geoffery stars like spoiled oh yeah whoa
Mason Disick with the shade and Jeffery
star coming through with a quick post
and delete clap back yep unexpected
faceoff started Wednesday after a fan
account posted a video of Kourtney
Kardashian and Scott Disick ten-year-old
son doing an Instagram alive with
youtuber Addison raised during the convo
Mason was asked by a fan if he had a
favorite makeup guru he responded that
he doesn't really watch makeup youtubers
but maybe James referring to James
Charles that's when he came for Jeffrey
Jeffrey stars like spoiled AF meanwhile
Kourtney revealed she deleted Mason's
Instagram account last week after he
started it without permission and
spilled the family tea no Kylie somehow
Mason has still managed to go viral and
now we have this unusual drama with
Jeffrey star and a now-deleted post the
youtuber tweeted quote I had five
hundred dollars in my bank account six
years ago maybe he's confused with his
own privilege versus mine being
self-made hopefully his father can
educate him soon fans are speculating
that the self-made comment was in
reference to Kylie's Forbes magazine
cover where she was dubbed the youngest
self-made billionaire ever when the
cover was released in 2019 Jeffery
tweeted the dictionary definition of
self-made along with the caption I
declined the feature so they had to pick
someone now this isn't the first time
Jeffrey has faced off with a minor about
two years ago he and James Charles got
into an explosive feud termed drama get
in 2.0 ironically during Mason's live
stream James commented love you Mason
just seconds before the ten year old
shaded Jeffrey although that past feud
was massive between the two Beauty
youtubers it doesn't appear that James
comment on Mason's livestream had
anything to do with Jeffrey Jeffrey
stars like spoiled yeah
[Music]